حدث يقام لاول مره اسبوع الموضه المصري
شباب من المصممين لديهم افكار جديده وخطوط
مبتكره في عالم الازياء اغلبها مستوحى من
التراث والبيئه المصريه ولكن في صوره
عصريه
[موسيقى]
وراها في معين له علاقه بالاوركس
المصري القديم
[موسيقى]
ان احنا
في عياده استخدام يعني
خلينا الجدود
يعلموا كل جده تعلم كم بنت من عيلتها
التطريز
وابتدينا نعمل احياء تراث والحياه
الغرزه والطريقه عجبت النزلاء عندنا في
الاوتيل فقدرنا ان احنا
نبتدي نسوق وعجبت مصممين كمان اجانب في
انحاء العالم ابتدينا نعمل لهم انتاج مع
ستات واحد سيوه
[موسيقى]
انا حاسه ان الفيلد ابتدى يتفتح زياده في
مصر بقت تثق اكتر في الديزاينر المصري على
اساس ان هو موجود في الساحه السنوات
الاخيره شهدت تغير في السوق المصري فبعد
سنوات من الاعتماد على الخطوط الموضه
الاوروبيه والملابس المستورده
ظهر جيل جديد من المصممين يسعى الى
المنافسه ليس فقط في السوق المحلي وانما
ايضا في الاسواق العالميه
[موسيقى]
وصلنا لجوده رائعه بدليل انه الصناعه
المصريه بتصدر لاغلب الماركات العالميه من
مصر يعني المصانع المصريه ارتقت بشهادات
الجوده العاليه بتاعتها
وكمان بنحافظ على البيئه يعني في الصناعه
المصريه يبقى في تدوير
للمياه المعالجه في صناعه في الصباغه
والتجهيز استخدام للخامات القطان المصريه
الطبيعيه الكتانات المصريه الطبيعيه
التصميم يحتاج الى الابتكار الصناعه وايضا
الدراسه احنا هنا مثلا مركز التصميمات
والموضه ده وزاره الصناعه عملته واحد من
مراكز تكنولوجيا والابتكار الصناعي هم 13
مركز في كل المجالات فده واحد منهم وهي
عاملاه من 2001 في كمان مدارس خاصه كتير
قوي
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات